welcome back to me rockstars I'm Eric
Voss and one division reports that
Quicksilver from the x-men movies actor
Evan Peters is playing a mystery roll
may haven't even deeper sexier truth
beyond our first assumptions I explored
the possibilities of alternate
quicksilver's being folded into them CUV
a multiverse logic a theory you should
check out but going even deeper into the
timeline of events and alternate
influences from the pages of Marvel
Comics and other clues recently
unearthed during our recent infinity
saga re-watch they all points to another
possibility
Mephisto Marvel's Faustian devil entity
who may have been lurking in the
background of the MCU since the
beginning since returning the reports of
Evan Peters mystery roll in one a vision
appeared amidst the news of production
for the series were zooming in July
principal production took place from
December of last year through February
with a wrap party on March 1st but it
looks like some reshoots will be needed
at 1 divisions panel at Comic Con last
summer
Marblehead Kevin Feige stated thin that
the series would directly set up Doctor
Strange in the multiverse of madness
[Applause]
series will be reflected in the tide
directly into dr. strange but Wow wan
division was midway through production
in December fine he began to back away
from those multiverse of madness
connections and even parted ways with
Doctor Strange director scott derrickson
replacing them with Sam Raimi the theory
I posed at the time was that derrickson
known for his work in horror genre was
planning on exploring the demonic side
of the Marvel world Fisto some of his
Twitter behavior indicated hellish
influences the problem with that is the
Chinese film board is reluctant to allow
films with demonic subject matter who
released sin its authoritarian but
commercially unavoidable market so it'd
be pretty hard for the studio to leave
hundreds of millions of dollars in
profit on the table by making its movies
antagonist a demon nope we don't know
for sure if that was the case with
multiverse of madness but we do know Wan
Division doesn't have to worry about
China Disney Plus won't release in China
anytime soon the streaming platform
could release a Winnie the Pooh reboot
with the face of Xi Jinping protesting
in Tiananmen Square while eating honey
from Tibet no one would lose their jobs
I mean it would probably start a cyber
war
but more of a cyberwar than we're
already in probably please don't make us
China anyway if the original plan was
for one division two establishment visto
just to set him up as the principal bill
in the Doctor Strange multiverse madness
these wanna vision reshoots and sudden
announcement of Evan Peters in a mystery
role they indicate a shifting back of
mythos tow from a mirror post-credit
cameo and Wanda vision to be more deeply
entwined in the plot of the one division
series
Mephisto was hidden as an easter egg way
back in 2012 in the first Avengers film
on that file Nick Fury gave a cap about
the tesseract
there was one paragraph that you can
barely see mentioning miss toes name and
in a digital version of that record
released by Marvel Studios this
paragraph was redacted but you can piece
together the original text to read now
they want to be used and deny certain
wishes
Mephisto has proposed that a billion
sentient universally linked will
couldn't overcome this problem and that
the cubes could be as powerful as the
infinity gems grammar issues there but
who's really looking at that in
retrospect this looks like a piece of
joss whedon's alternate backstory for
the infinity gems in the MCU before
Kevin Feige and his team retcon to the
tesseract as the containment for an
infinity stone moves that were made and
later phase two films in the original
Infinity Gauntlet storyline Thanos is
accompanied by metha Stowe who was
swapped out for his right-hand man
Eponine mah and infinity war mah even
steals Mephisto line my humble person
each
bow before your brandy but how will
Mephisto tie in with Wanda Maximoff
story and why specifically do they
choose an actor known for playing
Wanda's brother in an alternate movie
universe to play Mephisto look this is a
mystery even harder to solve than
whether or not you're carrying the
world's most discreet front pocket
wallet the ridge thanks to the ridge for
sponsoring this episode the ridge helps
you carry what you need every day from
their flagship Ridge wallet - their
portable charging commuter backpack they
want to make the most out of what you're
bringing with you the ridge wallet is
made of military-grade materials like
titanium and carbon fiber it is a clean
stylish design and his chainsaw proof so
you chain saw jugglers don't have to
worry about catching one on your side
you won't have to worry about the damage
to your wallet this is their black
titanium wallet they do have other
colors including some very flashy Tiki
designs it's light its strong and if
you're wearing black you can do sleight
of hand magic to fool your viewers
witchcraft they make it easy to buy with
free shipping and free returns and a
lifetime guarantee
it's got 30,000 five-star reviews so you
know they're doing something right they
also have great backpacks and travel
bags with RFID blocking pockets and
optional device charging batteries get
10% off today with free worldwide
shipping and returns by going to Ridge
comm slash new rock stars that's Ridge
comm slash new rock stars and use the
code new rock stars find the link in the
video's description okay Mephisto is
known as the deceitful demonic deal
maker two characters like Doctor Strange
Silver Surfer Ghost Rider but in certain
comic storylines Key has shown up with
Scarlet Witch and vision one omission
bear children William and Thomas but the
kids keep vanishing and reappearing
because we learned Wanda manifested them
be a magic they just go poof whenever
she stops thinking about him but later
on Mephisto reveals these kids to be
fragments of his soul and the witch
Agatha Harkness helps erase Wanda's
memory of ever having these kids now
later on Wanda's children return is a
plot point of house of Emma the huge
Scarlet Witch event that many of us
assume will be an influence for one
division in house of M Wanda chaotically
resets reality Nets him to be with her
hypothetical children it ends with her
erasing most of the mutants from
existence later on these two kids get
reborn as the mutant
Billy Kaplan Wiccan and Tommy Shepard
speed now in this one division series we
know these two kids must factor into the
plot the flickering sitcom realities
show Wanda and vision as parents two
twin babies and we see her in a kitchen
with fridge artwork showing the letters
be probably for Billy and T for Tommy
one of our recent big question episodes
explored the real-world ramifications of
the snap and the blip including the
super uncomfortable thought experiment
of what would happen to pregnant women
in such a scenario
what if Wanda and vision from their
opening bedside moments of infinity war
were with child Rin yeah what if she was
pregnant that cosmic dusting and
undestand could not have been very good
for prenatal health so what if those
babies did not come back with her their
souls snatched into the void beyond
reality that would definitely reframe
Wanda's rage against Thanos took for me
everything good God so imagine one
division as Wanda's desperate attempts
to reset her reality over and over to
try to find an existence in which she
can live on happily with vision and
their kids all together as a family it
could be a wish fulfillment spell
suggested to her by that nosy neighbor
character played by actress Kathryn Hahn
many have suspected she will be Agatha
Harkness
but Agatha's friendship is actually
two-faced because that witch next door
actually serves a different master in
the thisto played by that devilish star
of American Horror Story Evan Peters it
was Mephisto who stole the souls of
Billie and Tommy but he did it because
he really wants the soul of Wanda
Maximoff but again why Evan Peters in
this role well as we learn in Bible
School the devil takes many forms and
perhaps this devil will in his effort to
deceive and manipulate Wanda briefly
take the form of a version of her dead
brother Pietro Maximoff much like that
devilish god of mischief shape-shifting
into Captain America in the dark worlds
or the devilish ego shape-shifting into
David Hasselhoff it could just be a link
of the cameo of Evan Peters alternate
Quicksilver as he whispers to Wanda I
can give you everything that was taken
from you
like little brother and she's like
that's not my brother he's like yeah you
tried shape-shifting those traps one
does challenge and one division could
need to overcome these demonic forces
and use her own reality warping and
sorcery to conceive herself in a new
alternate universe perhaps by letting go
of vision but holding on to Billie and
Tommy in a new reality a revised and see
you with mutants I just got a pencil in
a little rewrite there there you go no
kama
comment down below and join our MC watch
alongs on discord by becoming a patreon
at patreon.com slash new rock stars
follow me on instagram at a boss follow
new rock stars and socials it's
subscribed more Marvel theories thanks
for watching bye
[Music]